[Music]  I'm excited to see Vanessa and today we  get to do something that almost no one  ever has a chance to experience today  it's absolutely gonna be a  once-in-a-lifetime opportunity and the  fact that it's with Vanessa just means  it's gonna be that much more amazing  don't be nervous I can't believe I'm  doing this I really I'm in shock I'm so  excited  [Music]  zero gravity works is the plane does a  series of up-and-down movements that  nauseous and I'm scared that this is  gonna ruin the perfect first date the  perfect first moment  horrifying I'm not in control of my body  I'm mortified don't puke can you  I want to get down on the ground badly  you